Grizzlies fan or a basketball fan in
general cuz this guy is awesome John
Morant out with a season ending surgery
for torn laam injured his right shoulder
during Saturday's practice uh as a
Grizzlies announced just minutes ago and
I mean it stinks it's almost like a Lost
season for the Memphis Grizzlies in
totality yeah I think it's unfortunate
because you saw some momentum um with
the Grizzlies with jaw back with the way
that you know you got baned playing with
the way that JJ was playing um but a
laam I I I was out for a season with a
laam um it's six months no contact you
can have so it's on a shooting arm which
is tough but um I think as a franchise
this is definitely one of those years
that you look to in these closing games
to be able to see kind of where you were
and what pieces you wanted to move
forward with yeah and the momentum he
was creating not only in Memphis but
around the league like it was good just
to have job back uh he got a taste
obviously and the good thing is I don't
know about the contact part but he can
still do some conditioning and things of
that nature so he's not all the way
behind the eightball but he got a taste
so it'll be good to get him back but get
healthy J he played nine games average
25 points per game and you went through
this kind of recovery what is that like
uh it's really slow and methodical
honestly uh a lot of it is the healing
process I mean obviously I did it years
ago but um with that it's surgery and
then it's you know you are limited
Mobility wise you're in a sling and then
it's just gradually getting back and you
know the healing process is the hardest
part because you can't do certain things
uh during that rehab and as professional
athletes you always want to push the
envelope and this is one of those things
where you have to be patient yeah when
you look at Memphis too I mean they've
had so many other players it's not just
J it's been you know Stephen Adams
Brandon Clark they've been missing so
many different guys that it's so tough
but they have done it without him so
they just got to continue I guess
continue on and I hope they keep some of
the Vets like the Marcus smarts the
Derrick Rose around for when J's
actually playing obviously he's picking
their brains and stuff right now but
when he's actually there learning from
them on the court and then B with him
and just different things the point
guard like d roll sees why he's out
there with him like I think that's a
huge Advantage going forward I think
mentally um it's got to be really tough
for J because you know obviously the
suspension playing a certain amount of
games you see how much he loves uh
basketball and loves being back on the
court and how much the Grizzlies
franchise was impacted um you know
having him back like Jamal said around
the league impacted just by exciting
plays I mean how many exciting plays do
we get for J from J in nine games he
might be the most viral player it's in
the last couple years right as far as
like on X and highlights and just things
like that I mean just the other day
against Victor wanyama right those those
couple plays that he made I mean you
just don't see most people do that
against him exactly and so I think
whether it's win or loss for the
Grizzlies the NBA is better with J out
there so I know it's got to be tough but
you know I hope he he rests up heals up
and and is back better uh for next year
if you had to combine two players who J
plays like in the past who would you
say I mean obviously it's hard not to
see AI you have to see AI you got to see
AI um I honestly I mean the way that he
attacks the basket I mean I I don't say
this often but like a d
Rish High Praise way that he attacks
that's a nice combo attacks the basket
what about you n n could you imagine
seeing a AI D Rose player in the future
right like we I see it now but yeah for
me I I
thought Derrick Rose and Chris Paul and
I thought the derck rose explosion but
he's like a basketball Savant the way he
plays he sees things on the court so
that was a Chris Paul element for me I
like that I just love that I like yours
better no I do I really the probing and
all that stuff that's totally that's CP
for sure as much as we talk about the
offense even the defense right the
blocks the big time blocks where he's
coming down those chase down blocks and
just making plays on both ends so it
just sucks for basketball fans in
general but hopefully John Morant comes
back healthy uh next
season